i think one of the greatest lessons from
2020 but also one of my objectives
looking forward into 2021
is that it will make your life more
special more grateful and more precious
oh my [ __ ] god we have to we have no
choice
but
[Music]
we're getting to the time of year where
everybody starts to look back
and where everybody starts to look
forward the long reminiscent
facebook posts and the new year's
resolutions that
ambitiously set goals for 2021 and on
today's podcast
i'm pretty much going to do exactly that
i'm going to look back at one of the
craziest years that i think we've all
probably ever experienced and look
forward
to a year that i hope will be much
better
what are the lessons i've learned what
are the lessons that we can learn
and how can we make this next year
better than the last
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody is listening but if you
are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
2020 this year has been a year of
increased perspective changed
perspective
i've got friends who have lost loved
ones friends that have lost their
parents i've got
great friends who are still debilitated
by covert symptoms and partial
brain damage six months after they got
the disease and i've got friends that
have lost their businesses
that have lost their livelihoods and
that have lost their careers and one of
the lessons i've learned this year
is that you know when the sun is shining
and everything is
going our way we don't learn an awful
lot
in those idyllic moments where
everything we thought about the world
seems to be
unfolding exactly how we expected it to
it's like we were right the sky is blue
and the sun is hot and my life
is predictable that's how it feels but
in a year like 2020 the opposite
happens the opposite becomes true we
have too much to learn too quickly
everything we thought about our lives
and how our lives are supposed to unfold
is thrown into uncertainty and
the very foundation in which we've built
our life upon seems
hard to trust anymore all of this
readjusts our perspective
for better and depending on how you take
it for worse
and we're left with a new perspective
which is less easy to sneak up on us
if that makes sense a perspective that's
less easy to surprise us
one that's less complacent more focused
more focused on what actually matters
and
who actually matters and less focused on
all the things that don't
if you're under the age of 30 or 35 this
was
probably 2020 the first time you've
experienced what they call
a black swan event at least in your
adult life and if you don't know the
concept of a black swan event it's
it's an event that is unpredictable and
an event that results in severe
widespread and often global consequences
for example the great depression many
many decades ago
although spanish flew in 1918 or world
war one and world war ii
or more recently the dot-com bubble 20
years ago in 2001
this generation haven't had a moment
like this in their lives and i'll be
honest with you it
really [ __ ] shows the sheer disbelief
by our generation that something like
this could
naturally happen to our cushy
predictable privileged lives is almost
nauseating i deeply believe this is why
if you go on social media
you'll see all of these wild conspiracy
theories
facebook itself is only what 16 17 years
old we've never had a major
black swan event in the era of mass
social media adoption
and the generation that used social
media haven't collectively lived through
really excruciatingly hard times like
many of our grandparents have
at any point in their adult lives like
this how could this
possibly be happening they cry it must
be 5g internet
it must be bill gates it must be the
illuminati can you imagine
if a black swan event like this like the
spanish flu in 1918
a pandemic that killed about 15 million
people
which is 30 times more people than covet
19
a disease that predominantly affected
young healthy people
imagine if we had facebook we know
so much about science now and we still
we still engage in this widespread
stupidity but back then we knew so
little
we were incredibly superstitious and
deeply religious can you imagine the
nonsense that we would have believed
the nonsense that we would have shared
and tweeted and sent in whatsapp groups
to screenshots
this is a point about perspective this
year we gained a very important new
perspective one that highlights the
fragility of our lives and the society
we live in and that brings
that sort of unavoidable realization to
the fore that we're
that we're mortal that we're not going
to be around forever that we're going to
die
and that life is riddled with
unpredictable but certain chaos
nothing is guaranteed not our jobs not
our businesses not our dreams not our
loved ones not our health and as i say
this
i understand why you might be tempted to
be consumed by negativity because it
sounds kind of pessimistic
but i want to suggest the opposite i
want to suggest
optimism and i'll explain why for me all
of this has
brought a level of optimism and
excitement and also gratitude into my
life
if none of this stuff is guaranteed if
all of the things that i've just
described aren't guaranteed if life is
to be as short
as just a bunch of years of which many
of us feel like we've just been robbed
of one then oh my [ __ ] god
we have to we have no choice but to
start living
we have to start living all this
procrastination all of this self-doubt
all of this fear
all of these things suddenly seem like
ideas contrived by
a mind that doesn't understand we're all
up against the clock anyway
that we're all going to become stardust
that only a few things
really matter our health our happiness
the health and happiness of our friends
and family
and those we love what an absolute shame
that so many of us you know what
including me
haven't given life everything have
allowed my
narrow perspective to lead me astray
many of you have uh if you followed this
podcast for a little while have followed
my life i'm
young i'm quote unquote successful in
business i'm
happy but even i even i haven't
fully lived my life i've held myself
back in moments through fear
i've not spoken up when i should have
i've
not told people how how much they really
mean to me
while i've had the chance i've let fear
make decisions on my behalf i've
procrastinated i've engaged in pettiness
i've been
consumed by a twitter troll who is
trying to provoke me i've treated good
people badly i've overvalued
superficiality and
undervalued meaningfulness i've hurt
people who have loved me and
i've avoided responsibility the
perspective
i've gained about the true nature of
life and the
fragility of this thing the world and
the society and this thing called health
which are the foundations which we're
all trying to build our lives upon
has made me realize how dumb all of this
stuff really is how stupid i've been to
hold these grudges to hurt people i love
to
hurt myself and to make decisions based
on what i think
will make society like me more not what
i think will make me like me more
or win approval of those that actually
matter
one of my best friends in the entire
world someone i've spoken to
more days than not over the last seven
or eight years called me this month and
told me
some very special news he's just found
out that he's having a baby
and i have lots of friends that have
babies but you know even my brother has
a baby
two of them but this guy is a guy that's
especially close to me so
close in fact that it's one of those
moments where like finding out that
he was having a baby almost made me feel
like
i was having a baby and it was
it was like i was processing the news
yeah did i
that i just found out that i'd gotten
someone pregnant and this is gonna sound
really [ __ ] crazy right but um
it's just one of those perspective
shifting moments on top of what's
already been an
incredibly perspective shifting year and
as i said this is going to sound crazy
but
i was on my way to the gym it was about
2 am in the morning if you know me you
know that i work out at crazy crazy
times
um and he'd called me he's on another
time zone in another country so he
called me pretty late
london time and as i was walking towards
the gym listening to my music and
walking through the streets and
i think i've shared with all of you
before the fact that it seems to me that
all of my ideas come either in the
shower or when i'm work
walking or when i'm in the gym i wrote
in my diary
a couple of phrases and i write these
phrases as prompts
so that i can develop these thoughts
later and also so i can remember to tell
you
all about them i wrote hurtling towards
death
okay this is a very think about it your
friend tells you you're he's pregnant
well he's not pregnant but
his partner's pregnant and you write
these phrases in your diary
hurtling towards death next phrase
receding hairline
next phrase what the [ __ ] is everyone
doing next phrase
why are we half living next phrase how
dare you
our next phrase create these memories so
i'm gonna go through those
phrases just one by one quickly and tell
you why i wrote them so the first one
is hurtling towards death we go through
lives not realizing that we're getting
older
and we don't realize that time is
passing right we don't see
age happening because we're there every
day looking in the mirror
so and it's so gradual we don't see our
parents getting older until we
leave home and then come back and see
them we don't see tai moving on
and so we don't really feel like raging
and also our friendship group
ages together typically so we don't
really again grant
feel the effects of getting older until
you go have those sort of significant
life moments
and because this is one of my best best
best friends in the world so close to me
that it actually feels like i'm now
a dad or expecting um
it made me realize that i'm getting old
and that i'm moving into a different
phase of my life
and that i'm aging and that
i don't have forever left
sounds like a weird thing to say but as
i've said in this podcast before i
genuinely believe
that 99.9 of us make our decisions as if
we're going to live forever
the next point i wrote was about
receding hairline listen my barber had
given me a bit of a dodgy shape up that
week
and he'd cut back my my uh
my hairline and i was looking in the
mirror and i was thinking i don't know
whether this the barb has done this or
i'm just getting old and it was another
thing i was thinking about that week i
was thinking i'm getting older
and as someone that has always
considered himself to be young and a
teenager
i'm also on my path to approaching being
30 years old
and all of these little things start to
make you think ahead this is probably
why people have these like mid-life
crisis
right and then the next thing i wrote
which was
upon the conclusion that i'm getting
older is what the [ __ ] is everyone doing
and this is maybe the most important
point of all of them because
when you realize when you have those
moments where you realize that time is
ticking
and that age is a real thing and that
we're not here forever
all of these stupid decisions to waste
time and waste time on p
and the wrong people in jobs we hate
doing things we hate
becoming incredibly stupid and i was
walking through the streets of london
and i was looking over at a guy
slumped in this bus stop wearing this
hi-vis jacket
and i was just thinking bro you're
getting old
what the [ __ ] are you doing and i know
that's a really naive thing to say
because it it assumes that that person
has choice and that they're making the
wrong choice and
life isn't always as simple as that but
it was just this moment of realization
that like
if everybody were to realize that their
their life was
actually on a clock and this is why i'm
holding the sand timer right now if
you're watching this on youtube
and why i have this sand timer in my
house and i had one in social chain
was because it's just the reminder that
sometimes i need
that time is real and that i'm getting
older
and to instill a sense of urgency into
my life the next thing i wrote
is why the hell is everybody half living
which is kind of linked to that point
which is if you understand your own
mortality if you really believe in it
if you really believe that you're not
going to be here forever which is a
lesson that this year's taught us and
that baby news teaches us and the
receding hairline might teach you
you make your decisions through a
different a different paradigm a
different perspective
and the next thing i wrote was how dare
you because after
really starting to realize that life is
finite and really having a moment where
this news and covid and my receding
hairline had made me start to embrace
the fact that time was so fleeting and
so special and so precious
i felt almost offended by myself but
also the action of others that we're not
doing more to respect the time we have
and then the last thing which was a more
positive conclusion was create these
memories and
lockdown and this year have robbed us of
the ability to create the memories that
i think we'd all hope
to and as i've gotten older
and you know i i think i shared on
linkedin and instagram a graph
showing that in our later years we spend
less time with friends and less time
with
external family and secondary family and
we spend more time on our own
i've realized the importance of memories
and seems to have hit
my friendship group all at the same time
we're all about we're all i think the
youngest is
28 in my friendship group and the oldest
is 33
and we're at that stage where we're
starting to realize that the most
important thing that we can do
spend our money on is have memories
great memories with great people
that we'll never forget and my
conclusive point was you know
i'm potentially gonna lose one of my
friends a little bit as well right so
this friend who's having a baby is now
gonna have greater commitments which
means it's going to be a little bit
harder potentially
maybe this is an excuse to create
memories with that person we're not
going to be able to travel away to
different countries
on a whim like we could over the last
couple of years
and um it just made the the desire
and the value of the memories we have
but also as i say the desire to create
more memories even greater
and it's funny we all have these buckets
in front of us in life
and these buckets have a bunch of
different labels on them one of the
labels
and buckets might be called career
success or family or friends or
meaningful relationships and then some
of these buckets are
rusty and dirty and they have stains on
the edges and they have a label on the
front of them that says
toxic right and and those buckets those
ugly buckets
are material things and social media
validation and meaningless relationships
and fear
and we spend our lives trying to figure
out which
buckets we're supposed to be pouring
ourselves into when i was young and i
was that insecure kid
that wanted to be white and wanted to be
rich and wanted to be loved because
i guess i didn't feel any of those
things i was so focused
and so compelled to pour myself into all
of the grotty toxic buckets and as i got
older
and more recently as the pandemic struck
i think we all started to realize that
when [ __ ] really hits the fan when our
perspective is
forced to learn 2020 style lessons
there are only really a few buckets that
are worthy of us that are worthy of our
time
and that are worthy of our investment
and
caring about something is a really
really expensive commitment
if you want to have a better life right
you have to care about less
things and you have to invest all of the
care that you save
into the things that you care about the
most
and that prioritization is a lesson that
i hope will stay with me forever
if there was a silver lining to this
year it was it's that it's the
understanding what i should be caring
about and
i think it's essential for you to
remember that
um that quote from i think it's marcus
aqualius where he says
um the attention you give to any action
should be in due
proportion to its worth for then you
won't
tire or give up if you aren't busying
yourself with lesser things beyond what
you what you should what should be
allowed i think that's the quote and
there's the other quote by marcus
aurelius where he says stop letting
yourself be distracted
that is not allowed instead as if you
were dying right now
live your life and those two quotes
again the stoic
philosophical assertions but they're two
quotes that i've
scribbled in my diary this week 2020
showed us how precious life is
so next year do not
do not let fear win you have to be
spontaneous
you have to book that flight you have to
apply for that opportunity you have to
learn to say i love you more even when
your ego gets in the way as it often
does for me
right you have to read those books you
have to start that business you have to
find the urgency to stop procrastinating
you have to block that
[ __ ] from your past that's dragging
you backwards
you have to learn that new skill that
language that passion
you have to take that risk because if
2020 has taught us anything
it's that we all have to learn to live
while we can
and the next point my diary is about
productivity and one of the biggest
productivity revelations i've had this
year while working at home
um i've been trying to juggle a million
things as we all have and i haven't had
the structure that has guided me over
the last five years of
i'm used to having an incredibly busy
travel schedule and i'm used to waking
up every morning
and just seeing my diary completely full
of
meetings and appointments and i just
kind of follow the the
my diary as if it's like simon telling
me to do something right
um but i haven't had that this year and
so it's meant that things have been
a bit more less structured bit more
unstructured
and so one of the the productivity hacks
that's really changed the game for me
is i've started working directly from
my personal calendar and not from
my to-do list i work for my to-do list
for a long long time and it felt great
it feels good to tick that thing off in
my little to-do list goes ping
which is some kind of psychological
reinforcement my mouth maybe salivates
or something which means that i've done
something well right
but i've been well aware for a long time
that i still waste a tremendous amount
of
time a task will take the amount of time
that you
that you give to it and to-do lists
don't have that time constraint so they
lack
that sense of urgency that sense of
priority and accountability and quite
honestly
a sense of consequence and if you know
if i don't do
the thing on my to-do list right now
nothing really happens so i can
spend my time off on youtube and doing
other things and
i i we all tend to do the the task
right before there is a chance of a
negative consequence of not doing it
and to-do lists i have to be honest they
still have a place
right if you need to write something
down to get it out your head or because
you might you know forget it
then by all means do so i i'm still
using my to-do list it still has a place
but once they're down on that list what
i would recommend
and the thing that's really had a
massive multiplying impact on my
productivity
is you then plug it into your calendar
um a little bit of a secret here which a
lot of people don't know a couple of my
friends know because they're all using
the same app
i actually built an app this year um
when i started having this problem of
not having a structured life
it's called time block and it's not yet
in the app store
but me and my friends use time block
it's an app that i built with a
developer
and it's basically a to-do list with a
calendar on top in essence it just does
exactly what i wanted to do and you
actually see
every time you block a task in you see
it like
fit the block filling up and it's quite
a cool little app that i've used but you
can just still use google calendar or
whatever app you use
um and so i put the the task the to do
onto my calendar and it gives me an idea
of how much time i have to do that
particular task it creates that sense of
urgency
and it's been genuinely a game changer
for me this year because the year has
been so unstructured and because there's
no
start and finish to our days and i think
i think i think people refer to this as
time blocking i think it's a fairly
well-known concept it's funny
because i've noticed that when i'm busy
i don't time block doesn't cross my mind
i'm too busy i'm being dragged by my
calendar
but in moments where i lack structure
like the weekend or when we're all
working remotely during a pandemic
i i have to time block if there's a
probability
that i could get very little done
because of distraction like on the
weekend
where there's less structure but more
chance of distraction
then i literally have to put all of my
tasks that day against my calendar
so saturday and sunday typically i block
out all of the time because there's a
high probability i'll just lay in bed
watching youtube videos or on my emails
or scrolling social media we're all
guilty of it
i literally put everything in my
calendar on saturday and sunday i put in
go to the gym and i put in two hours to
do that then i put 30 minutes in to eat
lunch
to walk my dog everything because
because without that
i won't be productive as i possibly
could be
if you do this already great you'll know
exactly what i'm talking about if you
don't
here's a little word of warning you have
to be
kind to yourself you have to be
empathetic or you will fail
here's what i did the first time and
here's why i failed i started my day at
7 00 am in my little calendar i said
right at seven am i'm gonna
wake up and do this and then i'm gonna
work all the way right through till
midnight
right the person in charge of putting
that in my calendar
was me right now in this moment
the person that actually has to do it is
future steve
right and so in order to be successful
you have to appreciate
the person who will be responsible for
following the calendar which is future
you
so i literally now i'm empathetic about
future steve i'll say okay future steve
you can have a break here where you just
literally do nothing
i literally put in nothing you can have
a break here where you can literally
just scroll the internet and go on
social media and
watch manchester united play um and
that's been so
so important i have to be empathetic
towards future steve
or i'm not being realistic and if i'm
not being realistic that i'm setting
myself up to fail
and um i wanted to share that with you
because this year's been so unstructured
and
we don't quite yet know what 2021 looks
like but one of the biggest productivity
hacks and one that will stay with me for
the rest of my life is this idea of time
blocking
give it a try huel has been probably the
biggest factor in the reason why i'm in
the best shape of my life
and i've been healthier in my body and
in my mind than at any time
ever before because the convenience of
pure the nutritional completeness of
fuel
getting all of my sort of vitamins and
minerals in one place
in literally 10 seconds with the berry
flavor which tastes like
heaven to me um has been an absolute
game changer to me
and it's isn't it great that i get to
promote
a product like huel at a time when i'm
in the best shape of my life where i'm
drinking
every single day and where i would
absolutely swear by it
and i thank them so much for 2020 and
being the sponsor of this podcast you've
seen we've been able to step it up
and that's because of julian at huell
that's because of huel
themselves they've been so kind to me
they never tell me what to say in these
podcasts they don't
message me after and say you [ __ ] up
plug this plug that whatever
they've given me total freedom to talk
about this product and fortunately it's
one that i can talk about for hours
and with total authenticity and belief
so if you haven't tried huel yet
just give it a shot if you're someone
that sometimes skips meals and your diet
sometimes can flake off
please give it a shot i'm actually gonna
say something um in part two
of this podcast about a friend of mine
um which is actually quite personal to
me so
i'll uh i'll pick pick up on huel in
part two as well
the next point in my diary is about
creating a greater sense of urgency i've
mentioned the word urgency
a few times in the previous point but i
want to really double down on it because
i think it's um
it's a huge revelation that i've had off
the back of 2020
but also as a consequence of running the
business i have for the last three years
with everything i've said i think one of
the greatest lessons from 2020 but also
one of my
objectives looking forward into 2021 is
to try and create a greater sense of
urgency in my life and you
some of you may be familiar with that
concept they call parkinson's law
which is that old adage that our work
expands to fill the amount of time that
we allocate to it
put simply if you have two weeks to
write a paper for school it will take
you
two weeks if you block out all sunday to
clean your house
it will take you all sunday if you give
something unlimited time it will risk
taking forever but when you're pressed
by deadline
we don't procrastinate and creating
urgency in your life whether it's in
your business because you're a business
owner of a global business or you're a
16 year old that's just trying to have a
better life is incredibly important and
by the way when i talk about this
concept of urgency it's very easy
to misunderstand what i'm saying uh
being more urgent isn't about being
busier or
about being more stressed or about being
more intense in your life or about
burning yourself out it's it's a
completely different concept
being more urgent is about demanding
from yourself that your most important
goals
are attained and achieved as soon as
possible because they are your
priorities
and by doing this you'll naturally
prioritize what matters and remove all
of the tempting distractions fear
excuses that absolutely don't
you know i saw this phenomena in my
business over the last 10 years
time and time again i witnessed on many
occasions on one particular occasion
where i'm thinking about one project
that our team wanted to launch
it took 18 months because there wasn't a
deadline
and on some occasions projects were just
never materialized i remember
a few years ago i had an idea which i
brought to the team and i put
i think like 15 or 20 people on an email
chain and i told them this like really
interesting i thought it was interesting
um hypothesis i've had which would
result in us building
a very innovative tool um that would in
my opinion
really shake up our industry and as a
consequence make us a ton of money
um i explained why i thought it was so
important and i i gave it to this this
this group of people to
to create and three months later i go
back to that email thread
and the group of people there are still
discussing it they're passing it around
they're waiting for someone somewhere to
return from
annual leave tom is waiting for ben and
ben is waiting for that guy
et cetera et cetera the idea had made
absolutely no progress and
to be completely honest i was pissed off
at that point i was fighting this war
that a lot of
sort of ceos or company owners will
fight when your company scales
and you start to lose sort of certain
philosophical values which
made you agile and are very much the
reason why you got there in the first
place
and my company had gotten big and i had
to start to trust people even more and
more to get things done and to maintain
those cultural values
and for whatever reason at that time i
clearly hadn't created the sense of
urgency that our teams needed
to achieve truly great things and i i
look back at that email thread
as i i observed um that good idea
going to waste because of a lack of
urgency and a lack of accountability
and i made the decision that i was going
to just do it my [ __ ] self
and i was going to do it myself
immediately so that weekend i went into
the office alone
and i went on fiverr which is a website
i've used over the last couple of years
to build
projects um remotely or with you know
external freelance support
and i asked a guy who was based abroad
to work with me that weekend to build
this tour 48 hours later
i was completely done the tour was built
and i took that
tool that i built back to the email
thread where those 15 or 20 people were
still discussing it
and quite honestly people were blown
away absolutely blown away because the
hypothesis
i'd had had been proven to be true and
it worked
um but it gets even deeper um a week
later i made a video
announcing this tool to the world which
we called
likewise and you can actually go and
check out at like hyphenwise.com
i think it's still there or just type in
social chain likewise
on google um and we posted it to the
world
that you know we tested our hypothesis
we built this tool
and we received thousands and thousands
and thousands
of inquiries and not just for a week not
just for a day
but for years we we two years later
we were still getting an inquiry pretty
much every single day because of this
one tool and i'm going to be honest
that tool genuinely made us millions
millions and millions and millions
it changed the game for us and it
changed the game for us for at least two
years
it taught my team a lesson and it taught
me a lesson
and from that point on i set up a
whatsapp group called
um move fast and make things and i put
six people in that group
and the only rule i set of that group
was that everything we did
in that group every project we tackled
we only had
two weeks to complete it so no matter
what what the project was no matter how
grand the ambition was that went into
that that group we only had
two weeks and i'm telling you this is
when parkinson's law which i mentioned
earlier in the previous point really
proved itself to me because we managed
to achieve
remarkable things in no time at all we
managed to
think of an idea and launch it within
two weeks including the video that we'd
made
including building whatever the idea was
including building the technology
in two weeks just because of that
urgency
it made us the six people in that group
break down walls that we
that typically we we all often create
that aren't really there it forced us
to reject excuses and it made us
it gave us no choice but to find a way
to make something happen
and if you think about that in the
context of your own life
if you think about all the ideas you've
had all the goals ambitions passions
dreams imagine
just imagine for a sec how many of them
could have changed your life
if only you had applied that same sense
of unapologetic
urgency and sort of accountability to it
if you'd said
do you know what this really really
really matters and it matters more than
pretty much everything else right now
and i'm going to start
now and complete it in a fraction
of the time that i think is possible
imagine how much you could have
accomplished
we can really use parkinson's law to our
advantage
because i've i've got this sort of
renewed perspective of the back of 2020
i've started thinking more and more
about urgency and more and more about
how
urgency isn't a way to to burn people
out or to
um to to to force
something through it's really a way of
of
acknowledging to yourself what matters
more than anything right now
and decluttering all of the stuff that
risks getting in the way the
distractions i talked about the fear the
excuses the
well we can't because or the pessimistic
attitude that some people
sometimes bring to you when you tell
them your idea in your personal life or
when you say it in an office they'll say
oh and it's not possible because of x
right
it dismantles all of that and it leaves
you with no choice but to attack
um the stoics who i study a lot the
stoic people the stoic philosophers had
a
had an expression which kind of links to
the first point that i made in this in
this podcast today which is
memento mori which is a reflection
on their own mortality and that was
their reminder um
it was their reminder that they are
mortal it was their reminder that
they should always be pressed by a
deadline and that that precious
deadline was the shortness of life we
all have a deadline
but as i said in the first point we tend
to live without one and therefore we
don't get much done and we we have
regret
and unfulfilled dreams and those things
that's the same urgency i'm talking
about
and the stoics used to say marcus
aurelius used to say that you can leave
life right now so let that determine
what you do
and say and think and they didn't say
that to create
panic or to create a sense of like
negativity or
fear of death it was to create priority
it was to create urgency it was to
create gratitude
as wonderful as it you know it would be
to if there was no such thing as death
no i'm going to take that back i don't
think it would be a wonderful thing if
there was no such thing as death
um but we can use death as a tool
i even when i start talking about death
in this podcast i realize that there's a
bunch of people at home that are
literally squirming at the thought
even the word because a lot of people
fear death right and i remember
once upon a time specifically when i was
religious up until the age of 18
i feared death too because i didn't know
where the [ __ ] i was gonna go
right and when you're brought up in a
religious home there's a higher
probability you're either going to burn
in hell
which is what you know you spend a lot
of your time thinking about or that
you're going to go to this place called
heaven that doesn't sound that fun
anyway because everyone's a bit too nice
right so i didn't really know where i
was going to go and it was it was in
fact when i stopped
when i lost my religion and i became i
guess agnostic
um because i don't think there's any
such thing as an atheist really that's
also
too much certainty for me um when i
became agnostic
that i no longer feared death i became
really really comfortable with it
but i think you can use death as a
positive thing to spur
you forward and i as a reminder as i
said in the first part of this podcast
of what's truly important
and how to therefore use your time
accordingly and if anything 2020 has
taught us it's
it's been lost it's been it's been a
year that's been full of death we i
think we've lost about 1.6 million
people
and everybody knows someone that's lost
someone we've been reminded about our
own mortality so in
in 2021 next year
be urgent urgency might just be one of
the greatest acknowledgments that you
know how precious
fleeting and special your life and time
is
and in turn paradoxically it will make
your life more special more grateful and
more precious
because it will fill your life with more
things that actually matter
and declutter of all the things that
don't
be more urgent that's one of my goals
for 2021 is to be
a little bit more urgent and people that
know me think i'm already urgent so
[ __ ] me okay so today i'm gonna close my
diary there if you're not already
subscribing
hit the subscribe button if you're on
youtube hit the like button leave a
comment leave a review it means the
world to me and i read every single
review
and i always look through it the names
that i've just subscribed on the back
end of the youtube channel
at the start of january i'm going to
publish part two of this conversation
and we'll continue to look back at 2020
and look forward at 20
21 tune in next week for that episode
[Music]